[Music]
since middle earth is coming back to us
this september with the new series
called the rings of power we are going
to dive again deep into the lore and
awesomeness of tolkien's creations which
are immense in quantity and articulate
in quality so here in this video we will
take a look at the origins the biology
and the life cycle of the orcs so
subscribe if you haven't already and now
let's get to it
let's start with the orcs description
and the different types of arcs that are
found in middle earth this will include
the goblins and the hybrids as well orcs
were a race of humanoid creatures best
known for their service as foot soldiers
and slaves to the dark lords of
middle-earth which includes the likes of
sauron and morgoth melkor orcs were
described as smaller in stature to men
on average strong but crooked in frame
and bowl-legged their sizes vary from as
small as hobbits to as tall as humans
their overall appearance varied a lot
and they had long arms and fang mouths
there are many sub-races of orcs and
goblins in middle-earth with the terms
goblins and ark being interchangeable
there are the smaller goblins of the
misty mountains of which most are the
same sizes as dwarves and some as small
as even hobbits they reside deep in the
caves of the mountains and most call
goblin town their home then there are
the snagger which are shorter arcs of
both isengard and mordor and they make
up the bulk of the army of both sauron
and saruman the hobgoblins are a larger
breed of orcs that are seen in the third
age of middle earth
then we have the goblin men the half ox
and
which are bred in the pits of isengard
and
in baradar by saruman and sauron
respectively the uruk hai are a result
of interbreeding with the hill tribes of
men and are said to have endurance to
sunlight and are as tall as humans and
even more ferocious the exact origins
and nature of the half-orcs is still
unknown in the third age apparently
sarman learned that it was possible to
mate men with orcs producing stronger
and larger orcs or vile and cunning men
it is possible that azov the defiler and
ball are actually one of the few half
orcs in middle earth which are actually
bigger than humans and were not created
by saruman their origins are still
unknown
so what exactly are the origins of these
vile creatures the true origins of the
orc rays are a matter of dispute among
fictional scholars within the
legendarium and tolkienus the fans of
tolkien there are many origin stories as
to how they came to be but none of them
are etched in stone the most famous
origin story is that they were once
elves but were captured and corrupted by
melkor and twisted and deformed to the
point where they no longer resemble
elves anymore but look like demonic bees
the first conception in the book of the
lost tales of tolkien describes another
thing how melkor created orcs or goblins
directly from the subterranean earth of
which they were made from stone and
brought to life by the dark lord
then there are also other origin stories
like how melkor couldn't actually create
life so he corrupted the druidane a race
of men who were short stocky and wild
and from them he created and bred orcs
this whole some truth as the half ox the
goblin men and the urukhai were a
product of interbreeding between men and
orcs and since they could have a shared
ancestry this would have been possible
then they could also have been beast
with a capacity of speech like parrots
but without a rational souls morgoth
would have then deformed them to
resemble the children of iluvatar which
are the elves and men as a blessed
famous mockery and taught them to speak
fight and form a culture that is
separate from the other races
okay so now with the origins done
even though they were confusing let's
look at the biology of these orbs let's
talk in a more sciency way here so orcs
are sentient creatures they walk on two
legs usually but at other times they
crouch and even crawl on all foes
they are vertebrates which means that
they have a nervous system shielded by a
spinal column of bones
they appear to be mammals and they are
almost identical to humans and elves by
the looks of their skeletal structure
and now that we know that there are half
ox and goblin men it means that their
genetic makeup isn't that far off from
us humans if they can interbreed it
means that they are more closely related
to us than even chimps and other apes
like gorillas or orangutans maybe as
close as homo sapiens and neanderthals
or even more so a subspecies
and although we have not seen a female
of their species
they might exist probably and most
definitely they will exist but they were
not shown in the movies and since we
already know that they can interbreed
with humans it means that they have
sexual organs which means that they
aren't asexual creatures and the females
either resemble so closely to males like
the dwarves that they cannot be
differentiated or they are kept in
containment elsewhere where they are
only used for reproduction and breeding
another good example of them not being
instantaneous creations or things that
just spawn from the ground is the
relationship between azog the defiler
and ball and since bulk is azov's son
then there is a direct father
son relationship and evidence and this
would be a seal to their sexual
reproductive nature
so with that out of the way let's look
at how long they can live that's also a
part of their biology it is unknown if
the orcs were immortal like the elves
but there is evidence or hints for them
having a very long lifespan azog in the
books not the movie actually died in the
year 2799 of the third age and bulk his
son
was the leader of the orcs in the battle
of the five armies which occurred in
2941 of the third age so there is
roughly 140 plus years between these two
events therefore putting bulk around 150
years of age
another evidence of their long life span
is the goblin king recognizing the
ancient elvish swords glamdring and
orcas which were used thousands of years
ago before the events of the hobbit
their long lifespans could also be the
reason for their huge populations as
they can have longer reproductive ages
and hence multiply
with an old mother probably having the
ability to give birth to hundreds of
children
so
in short what is the actual life cycle
of the orcs
let's just look at this with uh putting
into perspective the biology the origins
and all of that okay so ox were
originally either elves men or other
creatures
so let's just say that the orcs were
formerly another species then melkor
corrupted them and transformed them into
these dark hideous creatures
these orcs transformed by melkor still
had the ability to reproduce sexually so
coupled with their long life spans which
can be hundreds of years they can
potentially give rise to hundreds of
offsprings hence explaining their vast
numbers in middle earth and why they
were so hard to get rid of
just like rats and rodents they can also
interbreed with humans
uh with the goblin man urakai and half
ox being the resulting product of such
an interaction and abomination so let's
just say that that's the life cycle of
the orbs that's about it
anyway with that we come to the end of
this video so do hit that like button
for support and subscribe as well to be
a part of the mind cue family but most
of all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam